atisba valia beijing la semana pasada al
final del túnel cuando un par de noches
intensas de un contagiado land devuelto
a la casilla de salida hoy informaba de
74 nuevos casos la cifra más alta en
tres semanas lo que eleva el total por
encima de los 250 casos y lo que es más
inquietante se ha extendido a 14 de los
16 distritos de la ciudad como
consecuencia han regresado las
restricciones han vuelto a cerrar los
bares y restaurantes en buena parte de
la capital se ha el inicio de
las clases presenciales de los colegios
se han suspendido los acontecimientos
deportivos y numerosos complejos
inmobiliarios han sido confinados en el
inicio del brote está aquel que la
prensa nacional califica como el
paciente en
1991 es un joven que celebró a lo grande
la semana pasada la reapertura de los
bares antes de dar positivo el caso ha
puesto el foco en la falta de rigor de
algunos bares que están obligados a
exigir el resultado negativo de un test
realizado en las últimas 72 horas sin
embargo el joven no se había hecho
ninguno en las últimas dos semanas es
muy probable que este brote signifique
el final el joven supermarket uno de los
bares más populares y ruidosos del
distrito céntrico de sanlitun y al que
se han vinculado la mayoría de los casos